you're looking for a good time boom no
one would ever want that we're gonna
dragon eyes and so many pictures the
shallows Blake Lively my girlfriend
nearly escapes a shark attack and has to
eat a live crab to survive so today
we're gonna eat some extreme ocean
survival foods it's going to be geez
gusting so we've got some clams and
mussels and rock wherever you're at you
can probably find one of these guys and
eat it can you pretend that your mouth
is like the inside of a clam this is how
sea owners do oh nice sorry I'm sorry
I'm like your sea otter wife right now
Oh Thank You immigrants you don't have
to survive on this you can live on this
baby let's smash the clam ah do just die
just die I'm sorry's it looks like
everything sexual it's kinda like we're
making out with the ocean there's really
like one big tongue energy I'm very
horny right now though fish eyes ah you
constrainted somewhere dehydrated
apparently you can eat the fishes eyes
to be more hydrated hello people ask me
why I don't like swimming with fish this
thing is freaky hey Nick stop it I feel
like the world's worst eye doctor right
now ah ah I gotta get these eyeballs out
I don't know if I can do that what I pop
it out this way oh don't do it like that
no no no rehydration seems very
preferable right now stick it in your
mouth tell me how it is good taste great
jacket you're up Keith I'll never throw
up
ah no no no you can grab I got your luck
what you mad Eugene I don't want to kill
a live crab all you got to do is just
stab it really quickly through the head
what right through the brain we're not
in survival situation I don't want to
kill these things it's a reason cool now
let's just take them back to the ocean
and let them live yes of their life in
peace okay yeah let's free the crab
don't go okay to be happy I buddy hey
guys okay let's go this boat you guys
are the try crabs now my buddy
i buy crap of a wonderful life alright
well that was fun
you guys I'm hungry you don't yell like
seafood or something yeah oh wait crappy
reward I Oh crab cakes would be so good
right now
I'm becoming attached to the fish don't
name it Ned he's just a little
sweetheart
oh hey pretty lady whoa whoa